[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія, і настав
час для нашого уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся,
що ви всі щасливі та здорові,
тому що ми знаємо, що нам потрібно для цього, нам
потрібен спорт і здоров'я, тому давайте поговоримо
про спорт, але раніше  наш урок я
б хотів, щоб ми переглянули те, що ми навчилися
на попередніх, звичайно, ми проходимо
через усі назви різних видів спорту в
приміщенні, на свіжому повітрі, командні спортивні ігри, тепер
я впевнений, що ви знаєте, як використовувати "
грати і робити" - це назва спорту  ми використовуємо грати
з командними видами спорту, як-от грати в футбол, переходимо
зі спортом із закінченням ing і займаємося
іншими видами спорту, як-от йога, добре, ми
говоримо про футбол, найпопулярніший
вид спорту в світі, і у нас було багато
граматики про присвійні займенники та
присвійні прикметники давайте давайте
наша бабуся ми можемо сказати, що
це моя дужка в цьому реченні мій
поводиться як об'єктивно це
описує слово ракетка але ми можемо сказати, що
ракетка моя
в цьому реченні мій поводиться сам, якщо
він сам  як зараз, то це
присвійний займенник і це було ваше домашнє
завдання домашнє завдання полягало в тому, щоб вибрати правильний
Veeran з двох присвійних прикметників або
присвійних займенників добре давайте перевіримо
я покажу вам своїх батьків, а ви виправте
помилки добре
, це наша улюблена команда, наша ось
присвійний прикметник номер два не
беріть цю форму, це моє, у нас
тут є присвійний займенник номер
три, чиї кросівки там, блін,
вони їхні, тут у нас є
присвійний так, займенник номер чотири, подивіться
на її нову машину, вона - присвійні
прикметники  оскільки він описує автомобіль і
номер п'ять, ми виграли трофей, це наш,
наш присвійний
так, присвійний займенник good і подивіться на
ці зображення на цих малюнках, ви можете
побачити ситуації, коли, можливо, вам знадобляться
ці слова, наприклад, якщо у вас є
трофей трофей  ваша і,
наприклад, у роздягальні, де ви можете
дізнатися, хто це кросівки, платівка
чи куртка, це може бути ваше, це може бути її
, можливо, він або це може бути моє  добре, ми
пройшли через багато назв для видів спорту,
і я хотів би
трохи обійняти вас щодо назви спорту, можливо, ви
помітили, що в кожній назві спорту є
обладнання або щось про те, що стосується
інвентарю чи місця, наприклад, футбол у нас
є їжа та м'яч, тому ми  поставили
футбол плавання - це дія, це
назва спорту і місце, де ми вмираємо,
ми пірнаємо в небо, це дуже легко, навіть
якщо ви не знаєте назви спорту, ви
можете здогадатися, я доведу, що дивіться на цю
картинку, що це ми  є катання на ковзанах, і у нас
є дошка, і це так, ви маєте рацію, катаєтеся на
скейтборді, що ми тут маємо на горах
і велосипедах, а
ім'я - катання на гірських велосипедах.
інакше він стрибає,
він стрибає, тому ми маємо стрибки високо
в небо, так, стрибки у висоту, і
також є стрибки в довжину, і подивіться на ці
фотографії, які вони бігають, тому це
процес і назви спорту, які бігають, тому ці
види спорту люблять стрибки у висоту і довжину  і
біг вони є легкоатлетичними видами спорту,
тому що вони їздять на легкої атлетиці або
полях гірських велосипедів віндсерфінг
скейтбординг сноуборд стрибки з парашутом
підводне плавання всі ці види спорту є
екстремальними, вони дуже небезпечні
і їм потрібне спеціальне спорядження, а
тепер я хотів би пограти з вами
гра на пам'ять подивіться на цей слайд і
спробуйте запам'ятати всі назви видів спорту, і
кожен раз одна картинка зникатиме,
але ви повинні запам'ятати і назвати їх усі
давайте спробуємо спочатку повторити мені
всі назви сноуборд плавання
баскетбол теніс біг бокс  і
йога, а тепер твоя черга повторити і
наступний слайд одна картинка зникає, повтори
її зараз
наступна відмінно Я думаю, що тепер ти
запам'ятав усі ці назви ще одне завдання,
цей список видів спорту, які ми
вже вивчили, я прошу вас взяти
частину  папір, олівець чи ручку та
записати їх у цих колонках ці
групи, як-от індивідуальний вид спорту, командний вид спорту
або легка атлетика, зимові види спорту,
літні види спорту a  і екстремальний вид спорту, я
даю вам одну хвилину, добре,
так що дев'ять мінус час Ready Steady Go
[Музика]
давайте перевіримо, що у вас є добре, у нас
буде індивідуальний вид спорту йога, аеробіка
морква  Бойові мистецтва a carrot AIT називають
цей вид спорту та боксу командні
ігри футбол баскетбол теніс хокей
бейсбол і шахи, і ми використовуємо тут те, що
грати go or do yes play dragon
fields стрибки у висоту біг літні
види спорту, які ми можемо мати на відкритому повітрі
тенісний кінь  катання віндсерфінг взимку
ми можемо мати як у приміщенні, так і на відкритому повітрі шкірний
хокей сноуборд та екстремальний
віндсерфінг гірський велосипед сноуборд
скейтборд добре що ми використовуємо тут так
йти коли віндсерфінг йти кататися на гірських велосипедах
кататися на сноуборді відмінно добре, а тепер
подивіться на ці рядки що нам потрібно для
спорту це обладнання  або речі,
які нам потрібні для різних видів спорту, давайте
з'ясуємо, які види спорту це добре, лінія
номер один ракетний майданчик, що це
таке
так, цей теніс наступний  секундомір секундомір
доріжка і кросівки але не цукерки а
вибирай кросівки добре який вид спорту
так це біг велосипед шолом гірський
велосипед гірський гірський велосипед
так гірський велосипед і останній мій
улюблений ковзани музика і
каток що це за
катання на ковзанах добре, якщо ви не втомилися  Я
даю вам ще одне завдання, це
звуки різних видів спорту, і ви
повинні їх уважно послухати і
вгадати, що це за номер один, що
це так, це пінг-понг номер два
[Оплески]
це щось у воді так, ви можете, це може
бути плаванням  або веслування, але я думаю, що це
плавання так, ви маєте рацію, це там, де
вони потрібні, але так, це біг,
ви
правильні так, десять - це не пінг-понг, а не
теніс на
лугу [Оплески]
[Музика]
баскетбол і  останнє
[Оплески]
так, зрозуміло, що добре, так, це був
чудовий футбольний підопічний, тому зараз це дуже
дивне питання, чому ми запитуємо, чому так,
ми запитуємо, чому, коли ми хочемо знати
щось про причини будь-яких дій,
давайте  подивіться на цю кумедну історію
просто для розваги,
чому ти посміхаєшся, тому що я такий щасливий,
чому ти такий щасливий, тому що я хочу цей
трофей, чому ти взагалі виграв цей трофей
я хочу його, тому що я був першим у гонці,
а чому ти  задавати так багато запитань,
це гарна ілюстрація цієї
розмови про причину, але тепер
давайте відповімо на питання, чому люди
займаються спортом, і це кілька причин,
чому це відбувається, наприклад, люди займаються
спортом, тому що це командний вид спорту, їм подобається
бути командою або екстремальним  спорт або
індивідуальний спорт або спорт на свіжому повітрі, наприклад,
вони люблять бути на
природі з причиною номер два, це робить
мене чи когось здоровими ногами активними або
навіть дисциплінованими причина
номер три люди займаються спортом, тому що
їм подобається вигравати або змагатися
Махута  сер номер чотири, тому що мені подобається
плавати, мені подобається бігати, ризикувати.
Razoo karate stretching your stretching restying your stretching rest are elevation or just feel cald to be
Buddha Duda innovative
a  rtists porky і причина номер п'ять,
тому що це захоплююче або круто, або весело, або
небезпечно, або нудно, або дурно, люди
в цьому випадку, можливо, не люблять цей вид спорту
добре, ця причина, ми можемо вибрати вашу
причину і вибрати свій вид спорту, можливо, ви
можете зупинити цей кадр  і повторіть
причини, щоб запам'ятати, але зараз я хотів би
, щоб ви розповіли вам мою історію, мій
улюблений вид спорту - йога, тому що я люблю
йогу, тому що це індивідуальний вид спорту, і я
не люблю змагатися, це також робить мене
здоровим і щасливим, це  не дуже
захоплююче, але мені подобається розтягуватися і
відчувати себе спокійним, подумайте про свої причини
наступний слайд присвячений вашому спортивному
досвіду, наприклад, чи пробували ви коли-небудь
віндсерфінг чи пробували ви коли-небудь
це теперішній досконалий час, ви
пам'ятаєте це з попередніх уроків
чи пробували ви коли-небудь  Collinear Buddha
Holi це, мабуть, віндсерфінг, ви
коли-небудь пробували кататися на сноуборді чи скейтборді,
якщо відповідь так, було б
цікаво дізнатися, коли це було чи як
це було що було  чи відчували ви в той
час, якщо ваша відповідь ні, було б
цікаво дізнатися, чи хотіли б ви
спробувати колись, можливо, в майбутньому О, що
вам потрібно для цього знову, ви коли-небудь
пробували, якщо ви запитаєте мене, чи я коли-небудь пробував, я
б відповів  ти коли-небудь пробував
кататися на скейтборді так у мене
коли це було минулого літа, коли ми
пішли в гості до наших друзів у прямому ефірі, як
це було, це було дуже страшно, тому що я
впав і поранив ногу я
ніколи не буду робити це знову це небезпечно і
потрібно  спеціальне обладнання та вміння та
навички знання батальйону Джеймса зараз,
яка ключова ідея про нудну змію, тому я мав поганий
досвід, мій досвід
катання на скейтборді був дуже поганий, тому,
наприклад, якщо ви хочете виразити своє
почуття сильніше, будь ласка, використовуйте ці слова
дійсно так дуже страшно  дійсно
небезпечно, дуже погано, добре, тому
давайте влаштуємо невелику драму, не так багато, коли ми говоримо
про спорт, ми зазвичай говоримо про правила,
наприклад, що футболісти можуть або
можуть робити, повинні робити на не повинні робити футболісти
не повинні торкатися  h м'яч руками це
означає, що це заборонено
це правило, це дуже суворе правило, якщо
ви порушуєте це правило, ви можете бути навіть
покарані червоною карткою або штрафним вироком
номер два, вони можуть лише кидати пас або
кидати м'яч, але ця дія
дозволена  у спорті, тому в цьому випадку ми використовуємо
cat, коли правило дуже суворе
і заборонено,
ми будемо використовувати не повинно добре давайте подивимося на
волейбол у волейбол можна грати
всередині або зовні, це для двох команд по
шість гравців, вам потрібен м'яч і  висока
сітка ви можете вдарити м'яч рукою
або рукою
ви не можете зловити або утримати м'яч давайте
тепер виберемо правильний варіант волейбол
можна грати на вулиці під водою
в небі ваш варіант так
сайт можна грати поза номером два у
волейболі  ти не повинен кидати м'яч
ловити м'яч або б'є м'яч твій
варіант ловити м'яч так ти правий
і останній у волейболі ти можеш
ловити м'яч б'є м'яч протилежний
б'є м'яч так чудово ще кілька варіантів
я можу використати  спортзал без  членська
картка чи це можливо чи це нормально в цьому
випадку ми використовуємо can no ви повинні показати свою
картку це означає, що ви зобов'язані це зробити
клієнти без розрізу не можуть відвідувати
тренажерний зал вам заборонено приходити
без документа добре давайте  зробіть якусь вправу,
вставте в ці жалюзі, можете не впоратися або не
повинні добре ви ммм тренажерний зал це
заборонено не можете, коли ви закінчите, ви можете
вийти так, я стоматолог про мій зубний біль,
це болить
, тому я повинен відвідати свого стоматолога  і
останній раз, коли ти граєш на вулиці, іде дощ, ти
не можеш грати на вулиці, іде дощ,
немає можливості, і наприкінці нашого
уроку я хотів би показати вам якийсь
дивний вид спорту.
звичайно,
ні, але в Австралії є такий вид спорту,
добре, і ваше домашнє завдання ви
повинні заповнити пропуски одночасною
щоглою, чи не ви знайдете це завдання
під цим відео на YouTube
і правильні п'ять-чотири речення про
ваш улюблений вид спорту та причину, чому ви
подобається чи про ваш досвід  займіться деякими
видами спорту та опишіть свої відчуття, виберіть,
яким із них ви б хотіли займатися, а також для виконання
деяких творчих завдань використовуйте ці
зображення та створіть свій власний спортивний
біг та книги, будьте
здорові та щасливі, дякую і
до побачення
[Музика]